hello everyone and welcome to the game I
promised uh the game I played yesterday
from the creation chess League my
opponent was a candidate master and the
game lasted some three and a half maybe
four hours it was a really difficult one
for me to calculate and uh for those of
you who maybe don't have the the best
tools on how to face alin's defense this
game will uh you know show you a few fun
variations that you can use at um either
equalize or crush your opponent so let's
check it out uh like I said alin's
defense was on the board E4 Knight to F6
E5 Knight to D5 and I played Pawn to D4
and D6 he played uh so uh on the way
over there uh in my with my teammates in
the car I asked yarov what does he play
on against defense even though he's a D4
player you know just uh I I want to know
what he would play said that he would go
for the four pawns attack and while I
also uh enjoyed playing the four pawns
attack um uh when I was younger I don't
like it anymore uh I got this bookl like
maybe four or five years ago Kasparov
versus Simon palatnik where Kasparov
completely obliterated him with Knight
to F3 and ever since I saw that game I
decided that I will I will be playing
the Knight to F3 line here as I did uh
in this game but interestingly I did not
prepare for this game I thought he would
play alin's defense because I already
played against him once some 10 years
ago and he played alin's defense so I
thought why would he repeat it and if I
just prepare Al's defense I mean there
are so many openings he can play would
be wasted preparation so uh I I I did
not prepare at all but you know if I did
it' be great because he did go for
against defense so he played G6 I played
Bishop to C4 he played Knight to B6 and
I played Bishop to B3 in that game Simon
patnik played A5 against Kasparov then
A4 and then Bishop to G7 uh but here my
opponent went for Bishop to G7 right
away and now kasparov's idea I thought
about using kasparov's idea from the
patne game uh it's a really nice one
because cuz he went for Knight to G5
right away uh he attacked the F7 spawn
so he can uh play F4 right away for
example E6 and now F4 uh the problem is
um it's not as great as it seems D
captures uh captures and now Pawn to H6
because okay the game is different from
the Kasparov game without these two
moves I I have no idea if that's like
very important uh but after now now I
would basically have to decide whether
to go back to F3 and then I actually
like his position can play C5 Knight to
C6 or I go here and then I allow his
Queen into the game here nicely connects
check with my knight I have to go to G3
then comes C5 let's say C3 Knight to C6
and so on I thought this would be very
very good for him his entire board is
developed and he's the Alin player here
not me so I thought he would have the
upper hand here so I prepared Knight B
to D2 I want to play Knight to E4 just
not right right away we castles castles
I played he played Pawn to E6 and now I
played Queen to E2 again I could go for
Knight to E4 right away and I really
wanted to play this I just didn't like d
captures on E5 uh but the problem is you
can play this he's never going to take
away with the bishop because uh even
though he can trade Queens here uh the
absence of the dark Square Bishop will
be really be a problem for him now
already Bishop to G5 is coming Knight to
F6 check is coming so he really doesn't
want to give up the dark Square Bishop
uh but okay I didn't capture nor should
you Queen to E2 is the best and this is
what I played and now Knight to C6 and
here I played Rook to D1 now here I
thought about uh uh the position a lot
because I could sacrifice a pawn uh for
the initiative like I could go Knight E4
and if he captures here uh he could grab
my Pawn here and then it could be very
nice because I have all of these
developing movies like Bishop to G5
attacks the queen Rook to D1 uh but uh
let's say Bishop to G5 okay the queen is
attacked Pawn to F6 I can attack the
queen Rook a to D1 Queen to E7 I can
even go for Bishop to H6 uh and I like
my position a lot it's a really a lot of
um a lot of counter play that I get you
could play some Knight to G5 moves
attacking the bishop you could go after
the after the Knight here with something
like C4 uh the the idea is basically
that you're you're preventing black from
developing and you are having a great
time at it for example if C5 you can
even play Knight captures on C5 the
problem is uh after this Knight D4 move
he doesn't have the capture on E5 this
way he can just play Knight to D4 and
here it's not so so clear for me if uh
this is anything Knight captures Queen
captures Bishop captures on E5 now it's
a little bit different and although I do
get the dark squares I can play Bishop
G5 F6 uh it does seem to be a bit more
manageable for him Rook eight to D1 he
can play Queen to
D7 uh and okay it's it's maybe a
position you can play I'm up a p I'm up
a pawn uh but uh sorry he's up a pawn
but I don't really have all that much
counterplay maybe I do I just couldn't
figure it out over the board so I played
Rook to D1 uh D says Rook to D1 is a
very nice move so I'm very happy with
that and he here I was expecting kind of
D5 maybe he stops my knif from going to
E4 and then uh once he blocks the center
then I play C3 Bishop to C2 but he
didn't he wanted to sort of exploit the
idea that I didn't play C3 and he went
after my light Square bishop and okay
it's a very strong Bishop but I also
liked D4 Square for my knight so I was
very happy with this Pawn to H6 he
doesn't want to allow Bishop to G5 of
course as he shouldn't then Knight to F6
and uh now there are a couple of moves I
could play the engine says you should
play Bishop to D2 here but it's such a
weird move and I never even considered
playing Bishop to D2 here uh point is
that uh he he will capture you will get
the semi-open a file and it's just a
very nice developing move I went for
Knight to F6
check uh I thought I I felt like I had
to you know make something happen here
uh and my idea was that if he captures
he's going to give up his dark SW Bishop
I'm also going to capture on H6 for
example captures captures and now if he
captures with the queen I'm going to
capture on H6 attack his Rook uh he will
probably trade once move his Rook
somewhere uh and then I'm going to uh
create this um very strong center with
C4 and okay I like my position I control
the dark squares here I'm the one that's
going to be controlling them in the
future so
you know very nice and on the other hand
if he tries something like King H7 to
defend the H six pawn and then to go
after this I have Queen to D2 and I'm
just going to win the game on the spot
here uh so he went King to h8 he decided
he doesn't want to give up the dark
Square bishop and I played Knight to G4
now just put pressure on the H6 Pawn
twice and now he played Knight captures
on B3 a captures and King to H7 he
defended it and here uh I thought about
trying somehow to exploit this I'm
already attacking H um uh six twice and
I wanted to attack it the third time if
I play Queen E3 he's just going to
attack it with Knight to D5 so I thought
about Queen to D2 but I I couldn't um uh
figure out how to continue after d
captures on E5 now it's um Queen to D2
is actually the best move recommended by
the engine but after this move I
couldn't find a good move for him uh for
for me after Knight captures on H6 of
course okay he's not going to capture
here and allow Knight to G5 check but he
can play F6 and now what is this uh
looks okay but it doesn't look
incredible so I don't know that's why I
didn't play it I just improved my
position with Pawn to C4 uh and now uh
frankly I couldn't figure out a way for
him to get his pieces into the game or
to do anything he played Knight to D7 he
founded this one plan that he can
utilize I played H4 and he played Pawn
to F5 and I really didn't like this F5
move because I thought this can be
possible that he has uh that that it's
actually good for him to weaken his his
pawns like this the G6 and D6 pawn and
uh I I didn't like it but I also didn't
know what to play here uh I mean I knew
what I wanted to play I just didn't
think it was good that's why I spent
some 25 minutes maybe even half an hour
calculating this position and in the end
I played Knight captures on H6 uh
sacrificing a piece now the engine says
that e captures on F6 alasa and Knight
captures on H6 are both equally fine
they're both 0.0 only if you look at it
uh let's say we trade here and captures
captures captures and queen captures uh
if I look at this I've solved pretty
much all of Black's developing problems
black has the bishop pair I mean the
it's very very easy to develop here you
can also develop the bishop get the Rook
into the game I don't know I didn't uh
uh like this for white at all so I
played Knight captures an H6 and uh this
uh does require me to be done material
but after uh he he took material I play
Knight to G5 I'm sort of keeping his
King on H6 I'm controlling these two
squares I'm also threatening Knight
captures on E6 and it's not that easy to
defend if he plays Queen to E7 I can
just capture and now I'm attacking the
uh E6 Pawn uh twice with the Knight and
with the queen and once I capture and
attack his Rook is going to attack me
but now Queen to D2 check side steps the
uh the queen Rook battery and after he
moves I have Knight to C7 foring his
Rooks and so on so I was very happy with
that so instead he didn't go for this he
went for Knight to B6 now the bishop is
guarding the pawn as well and I played
Pawn to D5 uh and now basically I want
him to capture the pawn and I want to
advance the pawn to E6 this was my plan
and this is best for him he should allow
this and after let's say queen to F6
some see captures on D5 he's up a piece
but I have a defended pass Pawn on E6 I
have a monster Knight on G5 so I'm I'm
very happy with my counter play here but
he played D captures on E5 and this is
um uh not the best for him I played the
D captures on E6 now threatening the
queen he played Queen to F6 and now I uh
get back into the game because okay he
defended everything he of course um uh
wants to capture on E6 but he now
allowed C5 and around this point he
offered me a draw uh but I already you
know uh I'm winning my piece back I
already cracked his King's armor I don't
want to draw here of course I wanted to
continue playing so Bishop captures on
E6 I played C captures on B6 he played a
captures on B6 if he plays C captures he
gives up the D6 Square which is pretty
bad for him as I'm attacking it with the
Knight already so he played a captur on
B6 and I was uh below 5 minutes on the
clock here so I had to play very quickly
I play Rook eight to C1 uh I put
pressure on the C Pawn uh this the idea
being that if he advances it I will get
to the D6 Square for my Rook so of
course he doesn't he plays Rook 8 to C8
and I play Pawn to B uh B4 which I
frankly played because I did not have
time on the clock I wanted to gain
additional 30 seconds to calculate the
position uh but Queen to F3 was better
right away uh okay it doesn't change
drastically before uh the position plus
also it gets the pawn out of B3 uh but
um I uh wanted uh uh like I really just
wanted to get more time that's why I
played it and uh if he goes for
something like Bishop to B3 I I got Rook
D7 threatening Checkmate so it's not the
best uh so instead he played Rook fd8
he's playing every move pretty much the
only move he can in order to survive
this every move is a top engine move for
him and I played Queen to F3 I attacked
the B7 pawn and he doesn't want to give
it up but he should he should just give
it up play Queen D7 and get back into
the game but he defended with Pawn to E4
and now I play Pawn to F4 I threaten a
nice Discovery here while also
threatening the C7 Pawn he went back
King to G7 and I played Rook captures
and C7 there is an even cooler way to
play this uh but I did not have U nearly
enough time to calculate that is Pawn to
H5 looks really weird uh and it seems
like it's doing nothing but it's
actually coming to H6 which you can't
allow and if you capture then Rook to C3
threatens the bring the Rook over to the
G file so I could have uh played that
and even if you plays something like
Rook to h8 uh look at this Rook captures
and C7 check now and now after Rook
captures Knight captures now first H6
check now the king cannot capture
otherwise you go under the mask of the
queen and then you just pick up
everything so Rook will have to capture
but now you play Knight captures Queen
captures and Rook captures here and you
either get checkmated or you have to
give up the queen so there was a very
nice way of actually winning this uh but
I was constantly playing an increment I
didn't have time for this I was actually
super happy that I was able to play Rook
captures on C7 here Rook captures Queen
captures and now Rook to A7 I played
Queen captures on B6 and he played
Bishop to F7 here I remember thinking uh
okay uh I I was hoping he plays anything
other than Bishop to F7 because if he
plays Bishop to F7 I again had um to
re-evaluate everything because it's the
strongest move and while I still am
objectively winning uh very little time
on the clock and I have to be very
careful because Rook to D6 is the move I
want to play but then I allow his Queen
into the attack so I did play it Rook to
D6 he played Queen captures on B2 and I
played Knight captures on F7 King
captures and Rook captures on G6 so I'm
up a pawn and um I have my queen and
Rook around his King should be should be
okay uh but I I have to survive the
check so he played Queen A1 check I
played King H2 he played Queen to E5
check I played G3 and now he played Pawn
to F4 so now he wants to play F captur
on G3 and I play Rook to
G5 uh kicking his Queen away he throws
in a nice Vision to F captures and G3
check F captures and queen to F6 now I
have to worry about a queen Queen trade
Queen to F2 check Rook pushing the pawn
queen to queen to B2 check so all of
these are ideas I have to tackle with
always having 30 seconds on the clock I
play Queen to C5 going after uh Rook to
F5 to win his Queen he played Queen to
E6 avoiding that and I played Queen to
E3 I knew okay maybe there are better
moves but I want to stop his Pawn from
advancing I want to play something like
H5 I want to play Rook G6 uh and then
improve my position as much as possible
before this deciding for something
radical so he played King E8 uh getting
out of checks and I played Pawn to H5 he
played Rook to C7 now he wants to start
checking my king uh and I played Queen
to F4 attacking his rook and also
preparing Rook to E5 to win his Queen
and uh if he goes for Queen to A2 check
okay he can start checking me like I can
go King H3 Queen to E6 check I can block
and if Rook to C3 check and can play
King H4 and no more checks he can pin my
Rook with a queen D7 but it doesn't
matter I can even trade Queens here as
it's going to be winning for me I can go
for the pawn
here uh so it would be good so he played
Rook to C2 check he also uh started
getting very low on time here and I
played King to G1 I can play King to H1
if I play King H1 I allow Queen to H3
with check and I just get check made it
so I played King to G1 here uh and now
he played Queen to B6 check and he
played it very very strongly uh sort of
to a signal maybe that he he's out of
the woods that maybe he's on the
Counterattack now and uh there is some
uh truth to it because if I there are
three moves I can play here there's King
to F1 King to H1 and there's Rook to C5
one is losing for me one is a draw one
is winning for me so if I play King F1
uh and it seems like okay you're
covering C1 there's no danger here
there's you're covering this with the
Rook uh there's actually Queen A6 check
followed by Queen A1 and you just get
destroyed here so I can play King to F1
if I play Rook C5 he just trades and now
it's a queen and pawn end game uh not
really a lot it comes with check he's
also going to take this Pawn so it's
going to be a draw at best so I played
King to H1 and now uh he played Queen
cap and B4 there are no more checks here
and when I played King to H1 I uh had
maybe when I had like8 seconds on the
clock when I played it and I allowed a
few more seconds to drop before I play
it I took a couple of deep breaths maybe
like three of them uh because at once I
play King to H1 it was only here that I
knew that I would win the game uh so I I
felt very relaxed here so Queen captures
on B4 was played and now as he was out
of checks I started checking Rook to G8
with check King to D7 and now I play
Queen to F5 check which forces him to
any Square he goes to is terrible if he
goes to dark squares then I'm just going
to pick up his Queen so that's out of
the question he played King to C7 I
played Queen to C8 with check and he was
in this position on move 46 that my
opponent resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here once he
moves I'm going to win his rook and even
though he can give one one more check
that's all there is once he makes a move
um uh we can pretty much do anything but
it's let's say Rook G6 check King goes
here Queen C5 check King G8 and The Rook
to G8 will be Checkmate so uh you know
really weird game uh really difficult to
play against thein's defense you've seen
how many variations there are and you
never know when to put the Knight on e4
whether you can play it should you play
C4 should you tug the bishop back to C2
so many so many you know weird but I'm
happy with how it went and I'm happy
that in this position where it really
looked like you know yeah you don't have
a better move
than uh than play e captures on F6 alasa
that I went for Knight captures on H6
looks tricky but you've seen how I mean
with the undeveloped Queen side how much
counterplay you have and it was not easy
for him to make moves as well uh but
that's the problem uh you know when
analyzing with a computer the computer
will say he captures an F6 0.0 Knight
captures on H6 0.0 Knight to H2 the
engine gives
0.0 so you know it's like uh Anish said
in that one interview the position is
either winning or it's not if it's a
draw then it doesn't matter if it's plus
one plus two plus three it's either
winning or it's not uh so I'm very happy
that I went for the complicated
variation and I was able to get a more
complicated game and in the end even win
this very nice classical game uh so yeah
uh it seems that all that that I've been
playing for this past week on the
channel uh paid off uh you know I was
able to flush out all of my bad moves
even though I could have gone better a
few times in this game I'm overall I'm
very happy with how it went and that I
wasn't losing at any point or making or
or or that I haven't made some sort of a
huge blunder that could undermine my
progress that I've made it uh so yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it um hope I uh uh I I think my next
game is like in two weeks so hopefully I
will be able to cover that one as well
uh looking looking very much forward to
playing and covering it I would like to
wish a very happy birthday to AAS and I
would like to thank Mr hoodi guy Theus
on Spotify Peter marinov and an
anonymous person for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and hope you will have
a better time uh dealing with alin's
defense after seeing this video uh see
you
soon